that looks like you could still play a
little bit Willie McGinest the NFL
Network analyst do you ever want to hit
somebody like you ever have that urge
when's the last time you hit somebody
like wow like do you mad no not at all
you don't miss that like perfect hit you
know you know I'm around youth football
I'm around high school in college and
when I go out and I get to training the
younger guys and they they always want
to rough up the old guy right they
always want to see if I still can run if
I'm still strong so they like the tussle
so I work out as much as I can because I
know when I get around those young guys
they always try me so I might have to I
might have to get physical at times is
there is there a tackle that you think
back on is there a moment a hit that you
think of I think the most famous hit was
the Edgerrin James in Indianapolis at
the goal line
and I think I think that gave us
home-field advantage throughout the play
what did that feel like it feel great
because I outsmarted Peyton Manning
checked into that play because I stood
up and I walked out like I was in
coverage and he looked and saw me and he
like he does he's he plays chess all the
time he made an adjustment he moved
Edwyn over he saw a soft edge he was
gonna run the ball right there and then
right before the ball was snapped I was
in there like I'm not in coverage come
on I'm coming what do you hear when
you're at the line of scrimmage and
putting it into real time of making a
decision against Manning well it's tough
because there's a lot of cat mouse right
he gives you a lot of calls sometimes to
throw you off and actually some of the
things he says are actual checks so you
got to believe in what you see you got
to believe your eyes you got to read the
formations you got to kind of trust the
tape that you've watched because guy
like him will change things constantly
especially if he's familiar with you and
you're familiar with him so you just got
to base it on you know you study what
you study what you've seen on tape and
pretty much when you look at certain
formations you can only do certain
things out of that you just gotta trust
in that who would you rather face who
would you rather not face Brady or
Peyton
while face both of them because when I
left New England I like to clean I went
to Cleveland they beat the brakes off of
us when we went before we were when we
went up to New England so that wasn't
fun I would probably I wouldn't want to
face Brady because we're so close and I
would have to hit him but don't you want
to hit him no not really
because he's like family so I would want
to hit him but I would have to put him
down
I mean I couldn't finish him I wouldn't
feel right if I finished them so give me
a Brady story I haven't heard Wow the
ones I could talk about you know because
he does have a personality he does and
people he doesn't show it I understand
why he doesn't but like prior to Giselle
it felt like he oh man he had a
personality and it was low blood still
does he just understands you have to
conduct yourself a certain way when
you're Tom Brady yeah but you know the
fun times is behind the scenes that he's
always so competitive with every single
thing and whether it's drinking water
was the way remember in the 2001 when we
finish drinking water drinking water we
compete who drinks the most water
because we always feel like you got to
be hydrated yeah and we had a saying in
the locker room with Rodney Harrison oh
you understate you're always here to
talk about getting the edge or I have
the edge on you well there was little
little things like that who can drink
the most water who got there first in
the morning to get to the weight room
who ran the most gassers in practice if
you didn't who was walking or whatever
it was it was a competition did you ever
go out drinking with Brady we went out
had a couple of beers because I heard he
can Ross Tucker said he can not not
anymore because of this strange avocado
died with that he wants to play till
he's 45 so he can't he doesn't do those
things anymore
all right let me ask you about last
night because we saw the Patriots
defense show up a little bit here now
what do you what do you take away from
what you saw last I saw a lower
improvement they play more man-to-man a
little too man
they cover better they didn't give up
the big explosive plays and you hear
everybody now talking about the
communication well it's big
with that defense you got to be able to
communicate because when receivers and
players move when components of the
offense move our defenses change and for
the new players that are on that defense
now whereas before you may have been in
a system where this is what we're
running and we're gonna continue to run
this not in New England when you're out
there it changes from week to week from
play to play so you got to be able to
adjust and communicate and when guys
don't big plays happen mental errors
happen and it's a result of usually
somebody walking in the end zone like
Funches against Carolina it's a lack of
communication I saw in the first couple
weeks in the secondary where they're
just leaving guys wide open but I which
is bigger concern the defense or that
offensive line cuz Brady's getting
pounded yeah I heard you know I heard
you say that and and the defense will
get fixed they'll get comfortable
they'll understand what they need to do
Matt Patricia the defensive coordinator
will make adjustments up you know I saw
what happened last night that three
sacks the strip sack a lot of hits on
Brady
I truly believe in Dantes Carnegie the
offensive line coach he has been there
since I was drafted before I was there
he's one of the one of the guys we say
the foundation of the team he will get
that fixed he does not tolerate that and
I know he was he was almost pulling his
hair and biting his tongue off watching
what was going on and remember when they
played the Broncos in AFC Championship a
couple years ago he had retired he
wasn't there when he came back less tax
less hits on Brady and last night you
know you're not gonna survive long if
teams keep hitting Brady the way they
have so that will get fixed rustman he's
willing McGinnis the NFL Network analyst
you can see him throughout the week on
NFL Total Access at 7 p.m. Eastern also
the Tuck rule re-airs tonight at 10:00
Eastern on the NFL Network well know
they reminded they're telling me to wait
I know last night I had to hear that all
night like they finally explained it so
all the Raider fans every time I see a
writer friend you guys cheated we didn't
it's not our call did they enforce the
rule correctly I guess so after I
watched the time
I was like that was the correct call to
make and then they constantly made that
call on other teams and then people
start to get more comfortable but when
you're not aware you can't play the role
of victim playing for the Patriots
Willie dead sorry then when you're not
aware of of a rule I can tell you what I
did the first thing when I saw it I
grabbed my helmet and I was on my way to
the football field I didn't know what
the Tucker rule was I didn't study the
book like that the rule book
now Belichick probably knew we didn't
know we're on our way to the field how
do you know when Bella checks mad at you
his demeanor his demeanor what he says
to us in the team meeting room that's
that's the kickoff like the team the
team meeting on a Monday he'll single
young you're single anybody like
everybody's held accountable give me an
example like when you screw up when you
screw up he'll tell you and then he'll
show the entire day and you know it's
fair because if he calls out the best
player whether it's Tom without Brady
whoever it is yep
it's something that the rest of the team
can respect because now doesn't matter
who you are everybody's held accountable
so you respect that as a player will
continue with Willie McGinest someone
asked him our poll question if you could
take any quarterback under the age we're
gonna do 24 McLovin yeah just switch up
to 24 to include Prescott and Wentz okay
so if you could take anybody under the
age of 24 who would you take so we'll
continue with Willie the mayor of Los
Angeles Eric Garcetti
will join us coming up at the top of the
hour here Dan Patrick show
[Music]
what you got to use that a little more
violent oh no I did want to see that
because your again I can take it you can
take it when you bring it over to him
you get that slap right that slap to get
him here and you rip it yeah okay so the
club's quarterback Paul II is an all-pro
six foot 180 for high I'm gonna buy you
a watch what if you block them
successfully you got a move here I'm
gonna do this - here you go
okay now I'm gonna do your signature
move I'll sing it - move yet we call it
the pole on the oh yeah so I'm gonna get
him here
so I can create separation then what are
you going to shoot his hand no now when
you're gonna to stab me then I can go
here right and if he's like I could just
running but do you want you're trying to
engage with him before he gets with yeah
because I'm gonna lean in and go here
because that's the arm I really want to
beat that inside hand let's do one
that's okay look at for real yes he'll
for reals is we like this cuz I don't
want to see you I want to see you
62% the purple waiver
you're gonna go six motors for 60% first
of all you got a there you go clubbin
you call the play and that this could be
paulie's mile away on earth one - yeah
so I'm gonna go here and then he's
leaning right one more he's leaning it
he wants more well I got separation
right so I get separation here now come
back for any for any tackle that's the
hand they try to beat you with so now
I'm only working one hand right so when
he shoots this hand shoot I can go here
and then come with my swim or come back
and come here and when he shoots I can
just slap it down and go so I'm really
working half a man
thank you toriel here Paulie for some
reason it was this no matter who comes
in an athlete Polly wants a challenging
suit Paulie was going to try to block
Willie McGinest I kind of want to see
what it's like and Willie was very nice
he's a nice as well because he said you
were going for real for real and you
said yeah you go go 75% yeah Willie a
couple years ago we had Matt Forte in
studio okay I said give me a real shot
he goes real like a slap to the head
like a stiff arm slap to the head it was
a bad one yeah using concussion protocol
that's why they want it and then you got
a mean slap rep not yeah I've been
working on that okay is there a guy you
still have a grudge against they played
again no not at all
my grudges like once I walked off the
field unless you got personal I had to
meet you at the buses I left all the
grudge's on the field you meet somebody
at the bus I tried to a couple times to
a couple guys no give me an idea
quarterback a young guy from Baltimore
Ravens before had had a lot to say Trent
Dilfer
no he wasn't even playing he wasn't he
was the backup for Baltimore do you
remember his name
no not anymore I forgot can we look and
see the backup quarterback for the but
what was what was said that you were
gonna meet him at the box his
conversation like with me I could take
football talk football trash but when
you start to get personal and you start
to say other stuff like words that come
out of your mouth that don't coincide
with football then it's like I meet you
outside
I'll meet you after the game yours you
say to him yeah I'll meet you out to the
game like I'm not gonna I'm not I'm not
I don't condone certain things you know
as a man not Paulie like what kind of
names Anthony right Chris Redmond Trent
Dilfer Tony banks oh so oh so oh wait
Troy Smith all the trash talk and I
usually and I you and I usually don't
mess with guys
under 250 cuz that'll get respect I only
bring out Troy Smith it was too small at
that
I usually don't mess with guys under 250
you know but he crossed the line with
some of his verbage did you ever have
like a tackle that was a cheap shot guys
there's a lot of tackles that you know
they're dirty yeah I expect it and you
get into those little skirmishes on the
field but you leave it there but you
left it like you didn't if I feel like
if I played as long would you play 15
years 15 yeah there has to be one of
those where you go man if I see that guy
I'd like to I mean somebody going at
your knees that that was normal because
I was a tall guy yeah so a lot of times
guys would go low and in the rules what
there wasn't the same so they were
allowed to do so if I made you
Commissioner to help defenses because
that my whole thing is that they've
taken everything away from the defenses
right you guys really can't do anything
and they created this scenario where you
now go up top to blow guys up you know
that that if you're gonna make the
highlights that's really the only way
you can do it right you know they've
taken away everything that you're
allowed to do so if I said put in
something that helps the defense allows
you to be a defensive player without
worrying about getting flagged all the
time what would you do
Wow I mean the one thing I thought about
and I think they've to some extent did
it you can't chop block you can't go out
the guys knees so I think on both sides
of the ball if we put that in to keep
guys off your knees
whether it's a running back with
somebody going low and I understand
they're smaller and when I got a block a
huge defensive end Khalil Mack or
somebody like that they want to cut
block but that's the livelihood that
that right there your knees is your
money but you have guys who say Larry
Fitzgerald recently said hey come at my
head not at my knee when he says her
head of high misery chess area nobody
nobody wants to gotta say because it
sounds right it sounds were like then
what he's you know what he means what he
intends do not come at the knees the
knees is like pretty much career in it I
mean I get the concussion stuff and when
they say come high it's just okay and I
was a tall guy I'm 65 so when I tackled
I was never that low
anyway so I was I always lead with my
shoulder pad
give me the guy you would start your
defense with right now yeah mmm this guy
is three guys popped in my head Khalil
Mak JJ white and von Miller it seems to
be the consensus yeah how would you take
it
probably Von Miller probably boy he does
something that nobody else does it like
Mack it feels like can do a lot of
things in JJ Watt he does why Miller
does one thing and does it better than
anybody well he does that but he's also
you could also drop him in the coverage
okay you know when when you talk about
the linebacker position everybody
relates it to sax right just getting
after the quarterback but there's so
many different things like if you play a
New England offense they're gonna spread
you out and they're gonna force you to
take some of your best players out of
the pass rush and force them to cover
you have to be able to cover else you're
a liability so there's certain guys that
can pass rush and they can play the run
and when you force them to walk out on a
number two receiver or to cover
there's your matchup we saw it last
night with the linebackers on Amendola
yep I don't have white right yes no
Levante David no quad Alexander so where
did the Patriots attack mostly they
attack their their their linebackers
what theirs seems like yeah they went
after him McLovin give me the poll
question for Willie McGinest okay the
new poll question is if you could start
a team at the quarterback who's 24 and
under here your choice is Carson Wentz
hmm dak Prescott were both 24 Jameis
Winston and Mariota who are 23 or golf
or deshaun Watson we're both 22 Wow
[Music]
dak would probably be my choice either
dak or Carson Wentz see I keep bringing
this question up who's the best
quarterback in the state of Texas
deshaun Watson or dak Prescott right now
have you seen enough of Watson where you
haven't seen it okay I love what I'm
saying and what what I do know is he's a
young superstar and he's getting better
and
better every week what I saw from dak
one game in particular last year in the
playoffs against Green Bay what I want
to see from a quarterback is in critical
situation when the game is on the line
can you put the team on your back go
down and score points in a two minute
situation no time running out you're
behind whatever whatever scenario was I
saw that in the Green Bay game with dak
the only problem was they left 35
seconds on the clock and that's why we
we we put Aaron Rodgers and Tom Brady
and Drew Brees and some of these other
and Ben Roethlisberger on these
platforms because we've seen that time
and time and time again and when I
watched him take his team down the field
I was like that's the type of
quarterback you are the finger your
pinky finger yeah what what play thought
about that that word is it permanently
like that it is
we were playing the latter Falcons late
can you you can't pick yet could they
break it no well they could it's the
tenants but then it would be straight so
I would walk around with rather be able
to close my hand okay so how did that
happen so I was playing we play the
Kansas City Chiefs and I messed it up
somebody tried to go down and cut boom
messed it up so I was wearing a little
brace and attendants and then I end up
playing a lot of Falcons and they went
down again using my hand boom this time
broke it so the plate I had to get a
plate and all that a screw and instead
of me like I said getting it fixed so
it's straight and I can only bend the
tip I just wanted to keep it to where it
was so I have a little plate in the
screw in there but it's part of the game
we use our hands so much that's wrong if
I wrap this up and I came back just so
you I did not leave the game I came back
in the second half I have an idea how
about we come up with mittens for
offensive lineman so it's impossible for
them to hold and protect their fingers
yes tough what if I just let I allowed
holding everybody gets they doing anyway
I know but
they're allowed anyway I mean they call
it sometime when it affects you know
when it's right there but I mean it's in
the churches
you got expected it happens it's okay if
you were a betting man how many more
years for braiding legitimately I said
three three after this year yeah well I
said three total but explain Garoppolo
like you have the same agent as Brady
huh how do you just sit under contract
you know he doesn't have a choice I know
but then it's that context here yeah
next year now as the days go on the
Patriots next year I'm not sure you know
we've seen how many quarterbacks Hoyer
Castle all the different quarterbacks
come behind Brady in it to me I never
looked at age then I look at production
and a lot of times we get caught up well
these guys 38 now he's 37 he's 36 Brady
could have been the MVP last year
probably should have been yeah he was
the MVP of the Super Bowl broke records
in the Super Bowl how can you start
talking about retirement oh I look I get
used to play I just can't imagine
Garoppolo saying I'm just gonna sit here
for another three or four more years
no he hasn't make a decision he has to
make a decision and they're not gonna
pay him like they're paying some of
these like quarterbacks now yeah just
sit behind Brady have you been to
Brady's house not the new one oh yeah I
need because you remember the media now
no not at all we're still tight you know
and I'm wondering 90 to bring that up
where I have Gisele come over for dinner
what had happened family you know what's
going on guys you could have an avocado
smoothie or something and I don't know
I'm just
I think Rodney Harrison says you know
I'm kind of in the media there Rodney go
as Ronnie went I don't you know Rodney
doesn't leave is how you don't want to
go anywhere like Rodney's antisocial you
know you get them out you tell them you
want to go work out he'll get out there
Brady's always working out well that's
what I'm saying
but he'll have a medium at t b12 his
workout facility always got a workout
for sale connected to the stadium
it's just his it's t b12 that's the Hat
he always wears
he's so in so he owns what Alex Garrow
you ever hear about the guru yeah a
muscle to rush Lascar well they run it
together to rehab fitness facility and
so much more and he's so what like he's
so into preserving his body and finding
the new innovative ways to stay younger
stronger faster and all those different
things I think after this plug you're
gonna get invited to the Brady house I
think what you're doing is saying how do
I get invited to Tom's new house call
them yeah Tom I wanna come come on
that'll sound sad though no it's not you
know if if I say [ __ ] like mr. Kraft
sometimes right say let's have dinner
we'll just come to the house they don't
want to be bothered Tom can't go have a
regular dinner out in Boston Boston no
he can't we can't sit and have a good
time and just tum it up like brothers
and we just couldn't do it he still has
a bad body though right it's better
really had this in the green room I
don't know how do you carry that around
with you in my back pocket wow that's a
big back pocket there buddy says you
know Brady the book comes out yeah you
got it like you know we can do that
during the commercial break McGinnis you
can see him throughout the week on NFL
Total Access it's 7:00 Eastern by the
way the Tuck rule re-airs tonight at
10:00 Eastern I'm sure Raider fans will
be thrilled to watch that again and
again and again Willie thank you for
stopping by the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience